[Música]
buenos días eso soy un vecino de tigre
comprometido con mi ciudad que se ha
propuesto reflexionar sobre algunos
temas el principal es pensamos en el
futuro que queremos
de qué manera el presente que estamos
viviendo va a moldear el futuro y a mí
me preocupa mi futuro es el futuro donde
yo me tocará envejecer donde hay mucho
de ustedes empecé serán donde vivirán
sus hijos sus nietos los niños también y
ahí tengo una gran contradicción porque
yo se ve claramente que esté presente no
puede afectar el futuro
pero estamos viendo notablemente que no
es así voy a empezar a mostrarles en
esta película algunos de los malos si
somos 7200 millones de personas en este
planeta que interactuamos de manera
caótica con el único lugar en el
universo donde se nos ha permitido vivir
plácidamente desde hace 40 mil años
explotamos sus recursos naturales hasta
el hartazgo desviamos sus ríos
podemos
tiramos perdonen porque se me traba la
diapositiva
tiramos permanentemente nuestros
efluentes industriales y cloacales en
nuestros ríos y después vamos y tomamos
agua potable de los mismos miles y somos
contradictorios
bueno se traban seguimos trabajando
sobre este planeta de la siguiente
manera
arrasamos tierras arrasamos bosques
porque lo que buscábamos es producir
comida para nuestras plantas para
nuestros animales
y nos ponemos a pensar y decimos quienes
hacemos esto nosotros por qué porque
muchas veces de manera inocente quizás
en la búsqueda de poder suplir nuestras
necesidades actuales no nos damos cuenta
que podemos generando o contribuyendo a
un estrés global en el futuro
seguimos tiramos basura en nuestros ríos
qué hacemos qué hacemos con todo lo que
nos sobra en este planeta si generamos
basura vuelo a repetirla tiramos
nuestros ríos las tiramos en cualquier
lugar que nos permiten contaminamos
nuestras rutas nuestros campos nuestras
bellezas naturales cualquiera nosotros
paseamos por nuestro país y vemos que
hay algo común en todos lados es basura
por el otro lado para producir todo lo
que necesitamos para consumir
tiramos a la atmósfera como como si
fuera sido una cantidad de co2 que es un
gas que afecta a nuestro planeta de tal
manera que en los últimos 300 años hemos
duplicado la cantidad de co2 que hemos
enviado a la atmósfera la cantidad que
la tierra ha generado por desastres
naturales en 200 mil años o sea nosotros
en 300 años hicimos lo mismo que la
tierra en 200 mil quienes bueno nosotros
si volvemos a la misma pregunta por qué
porque yo creo en la inocencia creo que
inocentemente en la búsqueda de las
necesidades
lo vamos o sea vamos generando vamos
contribuyendo a un desastre global en el
futuro
se me traba en mí
en mis diapositivas perdón
cuál es el problema que tenemos con los
gases de efecto invernadero que afectan
como verán en la filmina lo que es el
balance de energía que entra y qué sale
de nuestra tierra esto calienta la
atmósfera es el famoso calentamiento
global pero acelerado y agigantado y
produce el cambio climático que es lo
que está haciendo el cambio climático
permitiendo a nuestros polos derritiendo
nuestras nuestras glaciares eternos
nuestras montañas acaben algunas fotos
de un ante y después de cómo está
quedando todo
y eso lo que está ocurriendo es que el
agua va hacia el mar el nivel del mar
está subiendo y sube cada año más
milímetro a milímetro eso nos va a traer
el problema especialmente a todos los
que vivimos rodeados de agua volvemos al
tema del agua
quienes generan todo esto volvemos a la
misma pregunta a nosotros por qué por
qué inocentemente creemos que para
suplir nuestras necesidades actuales
podemos hacer cualquier cosa con nuestro
planeta que nuestro planeta no tiene
límites
y aquí necesitamos comer necesitamos
vivir necesitamos divertirnos
necesitamos pasear y dentro de las
cuestiones está que uno dice necesitamos
comer lo que hacemos es que consumimos
tantos recursos de nuestro planeta otra
vez somos 7200 millones que no se nos
ocurrió otra cosa que cuando la tierra
se empieza a agotar le empezamos a
inyectar fertilizantes nitrógeno y
fósforo preferentemente
no somos consciente de lo que pasa y
pasa lo que está aquí atrás ese proceso
llame a otro entronización que hace
genera una salvas de color verde flúo
que ya se están viendo de los satélites
rodean todos nuestros continentes pero
no son inocentes porque el problema esta
es que no dejan pasar la luz solar hacia
capas inferiores entonces dejan de poder
vivir microbios pequeñas plantitas lo
que llamamos so plancton y fitoplancton
que es lo que después le da de comer a
nuestros peces o sea estamos en un grave
problema 3000 millones de nosotros viven
de la pesca o viven de comer pescados
esos pescados se van a quedar sin comida
si tenemos
seguimos con los problemas seguimos
nosotros en esta película mostrando
cosas esas son fotos reales de lo que
hacemos con nuestra basura volvemos al
tema de la basura hemos creado una isla
de basura que está en el océano pacífico
que es más grande que el territorio de
méxico ya hay animales viviendo arriba
de ella
eso es fíjense que muchos de los buzos
muchos recursos más conocidos del mundo
están alertando están las fotos el mar
está lleno de basura porque saben de qué
está compuesta esa basura por sobre
todas las cosas de plásticos
descartables en otras partes del mundo
le llaman práctico de un solo uso
qué pasa por qué porque muchas veces nos
da fiaca comer o cocinar en elementos
que después tenemos que lavar ya hay
muchos países que les han prohibido
entonces empecemos a pensar quién es
nosotros porque porque quizá
inocentemente no pensamos que podemos
necesitar cosas podemos solucionar esas
necesidades pero podemos estar generando
y contribuyendo un problema una
catástrofe global increíble eso que ven
en la foto ahora son pequeños peces del
planeta saben lo que tienen en sus
estómagos microplásticos esos micro
plásticos están en los pañales
descartables en las toallitas femeninas
y en un montón de pequeños sistemas de
sanidad personal que terminan en el mar
y ahí terminan en el estómago de
nuestros peces por eso también tenemos
que pensar el mundo está pensando los
científicos pero nosotros también
tenemos que ser conscientes de eso que
está pasando
como verán acabo de describir esta
película que es algo complejo
si es toda esta problemática es compleja
no se va a solucionar con algunas de las
metodologías actuales que utilizamos los
seres humanos del blanco negro sur norte
y derecha izquierda no sé cuántas
divisiones más en las que nos ponemos
cuando habitualmente los científicos lo
que hacen cuando tienen sistemas
complejos es generar un análisis y
sistematizar ese análisis y de aplicar
determinado tipo de sistemas el sistema
que a mí se me ocurre razonando como se
les ocurrió a otros también es ponerse a
pensar de qué manera mejorar esto
ponernos a estudiar
para buscar soluciones reflexionar y por
sobre todas las cosas accionar y por eso
estamos acá para poder hacer que ustedes
piensen que van a hacer hoy porque hay
un factor más que juega y que nos
empeora esta conclusión y esta
complejidad y es el tiempo hay algo que
que tiene que ver con todo esto y es que
no tenemos tiempo tenemos que actuar ya
hay llamamientos de líderes mundiales de
gobernantes líderes religiosos
científicos de todas partes del mundo
que nos están diciendo tengamos cuidado
dejemos de ser el ego hombre que es el
líder de este planeta que explota sus
recursos de una manera
insaciable y entendamos que formamos
parte de un sistema seamos eco hombres
pero seamos lo hoy les vuelvo a repetir
no hay tiempo
esta filmina que les muestro es parte de
lo que estamos siendo el black friday el
cyber monday la locura de salir a
consumir si pensamos si necesitamos
efectivamente todas estas cosas pensamos
de qué manera esto contribuye al nivel
de complejidad en el cual estamos
viviendo bueno hasta acá empiezan los
malos hasta aquí están los malos de la
película que somos nosotros
kirchner los que inocentemente creemos
que para poder saciar sus necesidades
del presente
si no nos damos cuenta que estamos
afectando que estamos generando que
estamos creando una catástrofe global
que está ahí a la vuelta de la esquina
les vuelvo a repetir hay límites
planetarios planeta es finito es hermoso
nos ha dejado vivir desde hace 40 mil
años pero está llegando al límites que
en algún momento pueden llegar a ser
irreversibles por eso este llamamiento
por eso esta conversación ahora empiezan
a venir los buenos de la película sí y
vamos a tratar de ver qué hacemos las
naciones unidas que es una organización
que nos abro a todos nosotros se le
ocurrió hace cuatro o cinco años hacer
una encuesta que quizás muchos de
ustedes votaron votaron 1200 millones de
jóvenes en todo el mundo saben por qué
porque son el futuro ellos son los que
van a tener que vivir en el planeta que
les estamos dejando uno de cada seis de
nosotros votos y voto estos objetivos
decidieron que para el año 2030 la
manera de solucionar los problemas de
este planeta era tener estos 17 guías de
acción yo sé que los que somos más
viejitos los que tenemos otra vida vamos
a crear
estas cosas son utopías pero los chicos
creyeron en esto los chicos nos están
diciendo que esto se puede naciones
unidas ha creado una organización que se
llama onu youth que es la que los
jóvenes en la onu que están generando y
están trabajando con nosotros los
científicos y con los vecinos y con
todos los que somos partes interesadas
en este fondo en este futuro en crear
planes de acción yo sé que por ahí
ustedes ven esto de deliramos con la
pobreza derivamos con el hambre hay
planes de acción y países que lo están
logrando hay gente que se ha decidido
jugar del lado de los buenos
si nosotros también podemos trabajar al
lado de los buenos dejemos de creer que
esto lo resuelven los suecos los
dinamarqueses porque piensan de otra
manera ellos pensaban igual que nosotros
saben la única cuestión
que se dieron cuenta que se dieron
cuenta los problemas que tiene quizás
porque en los lugares donde están fue
mucho más visible lo que les estaba
pasando
dentro de estas pautas hay dos cosas que
tenemos que entender una el poder que
tenemos hoy hay una palabra
empoderamiento el poder que tenemos
nosotros está en nuestra capacidad de
consumo y en nuestros derechos como
consumidor pero también en nuestros
deberes podemos consumir lo que
querramos pero lo que no podemos es
afectar los derechos de los que vienen
después podemos disfrutar de un lugar
turístico maravilloso limpiamos lo
porque dentro de varios años van a ir
sus hijos y sus nietos y queremos que
los disfruten y el otro tema es la
resiliencia esto que vemos acá que
varios los nombres que es la resiliencia
el adaptar la adaptación a los cambios
que vienen bien van a abrir muchos
cambios hay hay la tierra va a cambiar
un montón de cuestiones va a cambiar el
clima van a cambiar las aguas van a
cambiar los ríos van a cambiar las
montañas pero nosotros nos podemos
adoptar la misma capacidad que tuvimos
para ensuciar la misma capacidad que
tuvimos para empezar a destruirla
tenemos para poder mejorarla todavía
estamos a tiempo
dentro de esto planteó soluciones
bastante rápidas mucha gente me pregunta
y la solución cuál es a quién tenemos
que ir a ver no tenemos que vernos a
nosotros mismos toda la mañana y empezar
a pensar las naciones unidas están
diciendo lo empecemos volvamos a
nuestras raíces volvamos a tener plantas
como lo tenían tenían nuestras madres y
nuestras abuelas porque porque esas
plantas limpian el aire
hoy estamos usando muchas estas plantas
que ven aquí en la estación espacial
para generar oxígeno si vivimos nos
criamos en casas rodeados de plantas y
hoy esas casas las tiramos abajo para
ser locales comerciales y edificios
pensemos tenemos que repensar esto si yo
tengo mucho para hablarle de planta si
esto es lo que ven lo hice para que vean
porque hay mucha gente me dice yo tengo
un balcón tengo un patio citó pueden
hacer esto con cualquiera de las plantas
que ustedes conocen y que compran en
cualquier vivero que les va a producir
alimentos orgánicos no es necesario
salir a comprarlo lo pueden producir
ustedes mismos el otro factor importante
en este mundo son los niños los niños
nos enseñan
cualquiera de nuestros niños mi nieta me
enseña cómo debo reciclar cómo debo
separar basura que debo hacer con el
planeta
entonces escuchemos los niños porque
ellos están mucho más preocupados que
nosotros por todo esto que están
aprendiendo que van a pasear con papá o
con el abuelo a un lago pero no saben si
el año que viene van a poder volver está
bien y como verán les pasó varias
filminas más pero tengo que ir
terminando y con muchas más soluciones
quienes tenemos las manos en estas
soluciones nosotros
vuelvo a repetir si eso hemos sido tan
inocentes hasta aquí de creer que por
salvar nuestras necesidades de hoy no
pensamos en el mañana sepamos que
tenemos todas las herramientas cuatro
herramientas que vuelve a repetirles
pensar estudiar mucho y reflexionar y
ponernos en acción cuando hoy mañana
cuando ustedes lo desean eso es
básicamente lo que les quería decir
espero haber llegado a cada uno de
ustedes y espero haber cambiado un
poquitito de las acciones cotidianas
inclusive de las mías también de la
misma manera los espero para debatir
para los que no
porque de esa manera también mejoraremos
este mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]